He's the much-loved monarch who sets the chaotic
events of "House of the Dragon" in motion,
but why was the so-called "Good King" so
popular? Here's a quick lesson on the show.
"Game of Thrones" ended its epic
run back in May of 2019, and now,
"House of the Dragon" is bringing fans back
to Westeros in droves — though this time,
they're watching a story set nearly two
centuries before the original series.
Focusing on the powerful, dragon-riding Targaryen
family long before their descendant Daenerys ever
traveled on dragonback, "House of the Dragon"
kicks off even earlier than that, with a council
that chooses Viserys Targaryen as the new monarch
when there's not a clear line of succession.
Chosen over his cousin Princess Rhaenys
as the next King of the Seven Kingdoms,
Viserys is, on the surface, a fair,
just king with a good heart who's always
trying to do what's best for the realm.
"As king, it is my obligation to avoid
war until such time it is unavoidable."
With that said, it seems like those around
him don't take him particularly seriously,
and everyone from Rhaenys to her husband Corlys
Velaryon to the now-former Hand of the King,
Otto Hightower, frequently outsmart and
manipulate the king for their own purposes.
So who chooses Viserys as the next ruler of the
realm? Well, that would be the Great Council
of King Jaehaerys Targaryen, briefly played by
Michael Carter in the series premiere of "House
of the Dragon." Why does Jaeherys loom so large
over Viserys, and what exactly was his legacy?
Known by the nickname "Good King," Jaehaerys
I was one of the most popular kings in the
history of the Seven Kingdoms. Though his
fellow beloved king Aegon the Conqueror was
known as a fierce warrior and was the first
King of the Seven Kingdoms, Jaehaerys held an
important record as the longest-reigning
monarch in the history of the realm.
According to George R.R. Martin's
source material "Fire and Blood,"
Jaehaerys ruled the Seven Kingdoms
for a whopping fifty five years,
and by all accounts, they were
pretty uniformly good ones as well.
Jaehaerys' legacy is also pretty storied; he's
credited with keeping the realm peaceful and
prosperous, and he also was able to forge truces
between warring houses to keep things level,
including one between House Bracken and House
Blackwood, two houses of the Riverlands.
In his youth, Jaehaerys was also a formidable
fighter, facing off personally against Dornish
forces during a skirmish known as the Third
Dornish War, and in the early days of his reign,
he more or less created a system of laws that
would govern the realm for centuries to come.
Finally, he was also famous as a dragon-rider; he
rode Vermithor, who was the third-largest dragon
in Westerosi history behind Balerion — whose skull
resides in the crypts of King's Landing — and
Vhagar, whose whereabouts are unknown during
the events of "House of the Dragon" so far.
Faced with a lack of direct heirs, Jaehaerys and
his Great Council eventually chooses his grandson
Viserys over his granddaughter Rhaenys, but did
he make the right choice? As the series opens,
Viserys is awaiting the birth of his second
child, whom he hopes will be a son; though
it is, the infant dies along with Viserys'
first wife Aemma, leaving him heartbroken.
Though he then names his daughter and
only child Rhaenyra as his official heir,
he goes on to marry again and produces a son,
Aegon whose mere existence kicks off the
central conflict of "House of the Dragon."
Viserys is, for the first five episodes,
in miserably poor health and seemingly
ineffective. He's unable to shut
down the armies of the Stepstones,
leaving his brother Daemon and
Corlys to clean up his mess.
"Add it to the chair."
At the end of "We Light the Way," the
fifth episode, the king flat-out collapses,
and who knows what his health will be like moving
forward. Episode 6 promises a massive time jump,
and whatever happens next, it's
all thanks to the "Good King."